how amazing did that look anyway hello
it's great to be back at Gamescom again
if there's one thing that our football
fans know is is that we all love a bit
of banter passionate about debate about
who's the best where they should play
and who they should play with and that's
why we created this fat draft here we go
full draft well you give me the control
I'm on this
you put your important you have your
opinion so 43 best team that will play
at Barcelona I'll go go go big one you
convince me big decision let's choose
your captain it's got the message i
think i'll give you the fossa she'll go
on then but where's the shout coming
from nowhere messy thanks a lot i live a
little bit of import left but he played
there a few times battling much yellow I
think executive decision allover boom
let's pick a first center back I never
look at muscular Arnold I think he's one
cause it's renovated indignant I look up
around and his paces far in excess of
mask around i put the to fall but I'm
the completely back for move around she
wants central midfield we need a
balanced yeah he's gone for their this
might shock you I'm the gold Kagura how
can you pick caga way over to dinner I
made the decision I'm going agoura oh my
god what's the paint one this one
amazing that yeah well he's in he's got
a plague he's got to be into
steveandjenna debatable not amazement
look Oscar Stribling stats 85 Stevie 75
emulsion tech emotion out of it I have
the oven how can you not pick even
journeys brought to me in the team
greatest player for our club it's biased
and it comes from Manchester late-round
our kindness on the world you saying
give us the example Stevens you're nuts
playing I'm glad you pick you up back
right-center forward you only got one
let's look at these in detail analyze
and all the stats make sure we get it
right I've had enough of your analysis
daddy honest to god I'm Jimmy eyes
closed hurry k now they probably on with
that anyway come on let's look at the
subs also complete auto complete we've
picked our team I'm just a little bit
woodys not the team chemistry you don't
have to like each other to do well
together ok let's get this team on the
pitch well get on with it come on let's
go Oh what am I which 1i my pass you
lost the ball again what are you doing
how do you paint come on Guzman's in go
on run away run away from joy
I'm blue he's on the keeper
unbelievable unbelievable can't hug
honey so I can tell you that every time
that we Twain but draft back in the
studio that's exactly the kind of bands
are we here and fans have been asking us
for a new but experience for some time
and this is it and the best thing is
that all of the rewards that you earn
from within ultimate team draft will
actually go towards improving your core
ultimate team club so let's check it out
again we have to do is enter into the
game mode you'll select one of the five
suggested formations a team captain and
then you need to select one of five
suggested players for each of the
positions on the pitch basically if you
go for the best player or do you try to
build the best chemistry you'll take
your team online for exclusive high
reward competitions and try to win four
in a row for the best possible rewards
that you can get and obviously the
reason I love it is one you get to play
with the best players straight away you
also earn fantastic rewards and make
great progress okay so on to new ways to
play we're also bringing two of the most
requested plan features career mode this
year first preseason tournaments will
help you grow your transfer budget and
prepare your team ahead of the season
and you'll be able to choose from three
of nine tournaments ahead of each season
each year secondly player training which
gives your youth players a fantastic
opportunity to develop and also your
first team to enhance specific
attributes as their training within the
game you'll be able to select for more
than 30 drills and put your squad
through their paces there's lots
happening in career mode this year
including fundamental improvements
across transfers and scouting both of
which are going to bring you closer to
the life of a manager and as a player
now other new ways to play this year as
we announced earlier we're including 12
national women's teams within the game
this year including the World Cup
champions the United States of America
and your
very own German national team and
fantastic news they're both playable
here on the show for this year now to
the heart of game place we're innovating
across the entire pitch starting with
your last line of defence keepers more
athletic renew save animations and also
better positioning and FIFA 16 gives you
confidence in defending defensive
agility now means that the attackers and
defenders create a better balance game
and we're revolutionizing the way you
control the midfield smarter players are
better positioned to intercept passes
and we're also balancing the passing
game with a new feature passing with
purpose lets you move the ball with pace
and precision to find teammates and in
the final third moments of magic this
year with no touch dribbling it's a new
way to faint and change direction you'll
be able to make your opponent's pay with
better goals and of course lots of new
celebrations fever 16 is a balanced
beautiful football game and the sights
and sounds of FIFA 16 this year bring
the rich purple narrative to life with 9
iconic theater sauce for Bruce your park
and mention glad back and the epic el
monumental the home to River Plate and
you'll get to play new weather
conditions this year as well playing the
fog instead velodrome in Marseilles or
in the unpredictable rainfall at
CenturyLink Field and with more than 900
new crowd chants you'll be able to sing
your way to victory
so as you can see that's real madrid
they're the most play team in FIFA and
some numbers for you basically the most
played means that every day more than
1.3 million matches are played with real
madrid so it's a star-studded club and
we obviously wanted to bring the top
authenticity to the madrid players and
we've raised them to a new Neville this
year in FIFA 16 we're also bringing fans
closer to the club and that starts today
so I'm going to take a little pause
right now and ask all of you to do
something I'm out to give away four
tickets to arguably the best match in
the football calendar this year el
clásico obviously between real madrid
and FC barcelona two tickets to people
in this room and two to someone watching
online at home so if you're watching
online tweeter sir a at EA sports fifa
with the hashtag vp-16 about what you
love about FIFA 16 and we'll pick a
winner within the next hour if you're in
the right in the room right now though
take your hand reach underneath your
seat and somewhere in this room is
someone with two tickets to that match
as anybody got two tickets I don't know
where they are so reach under hopefully
they've not been taken is that you he's
got an envelope there you go
congratulations two tickets to the game
so enjoy that
you lucky fellow thanks to our new
partners route Madrid for helping sort
us out with that one and so just before
I wrap things up we've got one more
thing for Germany specifically last year
you may remember we bought an all new
level of gameday authenticity to the
Barclays Premier League matches and fans
loved it so this year we're going to
recreate that level of broadcast
authenticity for the Bundesliga you'll
see score graphics team sheets player
analysis true to what you see when
you're watching the games on television
here in Germany and around the world
it's truly authentic so this year with
FIFA 16 all new ways to play fifa
innovation across the entire pitch and a
rich football narrative driven by the
sights and sound of the most beautiful
game in the world so that's me done it's
been a pleasure being here and leave you
with something that just shows off how
beautiful the new season will be thank
you very much
he sport returns for another year of
drama entry beauty and suspense
football is back
laughs
has come along
and here we
nificent gone
to go
that is why
the beautiful game
you